as our planet warms up due to the
greenhouse effect the vast majority of
trapped heat is absorbed by the oceans
over 90 percent of it the oceans
therefore provide a key buffer that
helps keep temperatures on our planet
stable but their capacity to absorb heat
isn't endless and marine ecosystems are
suffering organisms like corals that
can't flee the higher temperatures
simply die
back-to-back bleaching and catastrophic
mortality is meant we've lost 50% of all
corals on the Great Barrier Reef in two
years and this has meant we've needed
entirely new ways to think about how can
we fast track both resilience and
recovery and warmer oceans are having
another major impact on our planets
colder regions even a slight rise in
water temperature causes glaciers to
melt more rapidly from below billions of
tons of ice have already disappeared
from the ice caps in a nutshell warmer
ocean temperatures mean rising sea
levels diminished marine biodiversity
and more powerful storms
Ranjan from T W environment can talk us
through this certain new research a
welcome to the studio Majid it seems
that a day doesn't go by without us
hearing more bad news about the planet
is there anything in these findings that
we didn't already know
oceans are getting warmer and we're all
essentially gonna die we're all doomed
so we're not all doomed which has
obviously a nice thing to be able to say
but we would like to say better things
on that the report showed that 2019 with
the warmest year on record and I mean
this is becoming a regular occurrence
2019 was warmer than 2018 which form
than 2017 and I mean this whole decade
for the same and one thing that is
incredibly striking from the report is
that the scientists calculated the
amount of energy thermal energy that's
kind of been added to the oceans and
said that it's essentially the
equivalent of having dropped three point
six billion atom bombs in her water into
the water that's I don't understand what
that means
no so I mean obviously let's just make
sure we understand that obviously 3.6
billion bombs have not been dropped into
the water and
the destruction is not of that level but
what it does show is the quantity of
thermal energy by which we have raised
the oceans and I mean another study the
author's told me that essentially just
the jump from 2018 to 2019 in terms of
ocean heat was roughly 44 times larger
than the entire direct energy used by
humans across the world and that's
essentially because of this greenhouse
gas effect so we're burning these fossil
fuels they're releasing gases into the
atmosphere and these are then trapping
solar energy essentially so it's not
just the lump of coal that you burn
that's warming the oceans right it's the
gases that are released from that a trap
other energy so here's the thing right
this is happening in the oceans this is
what we're talking about so if I don't
live on the coast if I don't live in a
small Pacific island why do I care so
one thing all the scientists have spoken
to all the ocean scientists I've ever
spoken to have said is that this whole
thing is really interconnected so even
if you live in a landlocked country and
are far away from things I mean you're
dependent on the global food supply
presumably and if I don't know rising
sea levels or from warmer waters affect
crop production in a rice growing in the
Mekong Basin then of course you're then
affected by these things on a more sort
of maybe direct level for these coastal
communities in particular and for
countries which have a large amount of
coastline this warmer water leads to
rising sea levels and that means that
people on these in these cities are
exposed to more intense storms and often
more frequent flooding in some areas and
so directly people are affected by this
okay so and these are all the phenomena
that we are seeing so where's the good
news the good news is that we know what
to do about it essentially we need to
both mitigate again and this is what
scientists are telling us we need to
mitigate against global warming so we
need to reduce the amount of greenhouse
gas emissions into the atmosphere so
reducing this warming effect on the
planet and that will lower the scale of
the problem itself but we've already
locked in a certain amount of warming
because of the
we've already pumped out and particular
for the oceans because they're really
slow to react to changes in the
atmosphere and all that means that we
also need to adapt against what's
already happened and what is set to come
because without sharp and steep cuts in
greenhouse gas emissions
we are set for a large amounts of
warming okay I didn't see that it's
necessary that good news but do you give
you bastard you can your own job from DW
environment thank you